hi my name is random unsuccessful actor  and i'm going to be reading the part for  tree stump you can begin when you're  ready hey you can't sit on me thank you  next ah i knew this would happen because  i'm from a small i'm from oklahoma  you're just a small atom in a vast and  meaningless universe no one loves you  you will die alone hold on i'm the  director on this motion picture who are  you i want you to be the star of this  picture sounds good i know talent when i  see it and you definitely have value as  a human being you should definitely  not be sad sounds good and uh i'm your  father figure now sounds good and i  definitely won't betray you in the  second act oh one last thing hit casting  director yes i love you  thank you yeah